turkey has started sending Islamic state
fighters who were captured in Syria back
to their home countries the fighters
have been held at deportation centres in
Turkey and according to the country's
interior ministry the first to be
repatriated is a US citizen
a German combatant will be sent back
today as well with more to be
repatriated later this week let's get
more on the story with our correspondent
Dorian Jones he's standing by for us in
Istanbul hi Dorian what more can you
tell us about what the Turkish
government is doing here well that's
right the interior ministry spokesman is
now at a close been speaking saying that
one American citizen has already been
deported today there will be another
German and a Danish citizen are expected
to be returned later on today back to
their countries and on Thursday there
will be seven more German citizens again
linked to the Islamic state will be
returned and possibly 11 French citizens
also two other Germans are expected
later this week as well so this is all
part of Turkey's commitment to return
back foreign fighters to their homeland
now this does pose a particular
diplomatic tension will be given the
fact that some of these are fighters are
believed have had their citizenship
renounced by their countries that they
are from both the Turkish interior
minister salomon solo has been very
clear he says he sees it as nothing more
than a ematic ploy he says Turkey will
not be a hotel for these Islamist
terrorists and is up to European
countries to take their responsibility
so there is potentially a looming
diplomatic tension that could be lower
Rowlett could be brewing over this but
hunker is clear these these Islamic
state fighters have to go back home what
about the timing of the story and why is
this happening now well this is hauling
that Turkey has had believed to be
dozens possibly a few hundred foreign
fighters linked to Islamic state in
their jails but also turkeys now be
involved in his military operation into
Syria it has taken control of a stripper
around 120 kilometres 30 kilometres deep
and now in that area there are a
presence of Islamic state fighters and
which some are believed to be foreign
nationals and Turkey possibly in talks
with Washington and and other countries
in the region could be
taking control of other prisons help of
Islamic state fighters of which they
believed to be hundreds if not thousands
of Islamic state fighters in those camps
an anchor is clear all those countries
where they are from have to take them
back whether they have a citizenship or
not anchor is clear that is not a hotel
and doesn't expect Syria to be a hotel
for these fighters our correspondent
Doreen Jones speaking to us from
Istanbul thank you well Turkey's move to
repatriate fighters of the so-called
Islamic state comes as more evidence as
being uncovered of the jihadi groups
crimes in Syria
here's more more and more mass graves of
people killed by Islamic state of being
found in Syria thousands of soldiers and
civilians were murdered while is
controlled territory they're often for
allegedly breaking Islamic law many is
fighters and their families have been
held in detention camps run by Syrian
Kurdish forces they in the United States
have been calling on Germany to take
back a German is detainees young a
carload the Americans and the Syrian
Kurds have removed a serious threat to
our domestic security if they ask
Germany to take back 20 fighters and a
few women we shouldn't dismiss very
quest but that is exactly what the
German government is doing as Wiggio
Alba foreign minister hai Kumar says
readmitting German is members would
represent a danger to Germany if there's
not enough evidence to charge them with
any crimes we need information about the
relevant individuals in order to launch
an investigation or criminal proceedings
or keep them in detention it's a
difficult process experts argue that us
and German investigators have already
gathered plenty of evidence in Syria by
questioning witnesses and suspects
inform us wonder if there should be
enough information perhaps the
government is frightens that any
resorting prison sentences would be so
brief that those individuals would soon
be free again I let you serve it off
hike on the Turkish offensive in Syria
has raised the pressure on Germany to
take back German is members suspected of
crimes a number of them have reportedly
escaped from detention camps in recent
weeks
normos security risk if people escape
and come back to Germany a will the
danger is much greater than if an
orderly repatriation is organized with
the knowledge of the security services
it's especially German women detainees
who've renounced their allegiance to
Islamic state who are hoping for that
kind of repatriation they faced abuse
and threats from other detainees still
loyal to is among them is Zainab gergan
from Berlin it's terrible what crimes is
has committed in the name of Islam all I
want is to be allowed to come home to my
beloved Germany hi Martin and Iceland
whether or not zina Jurgen has committed
any crimes she so far not been allowed
to return home but for her and her
two-year-old son that's all she hopes
for let's bring in our political
correspondent max Emiliana Koscheck on
this story
hi max the German government has been
skeptical of taking back is fighters
from Syria has Berlin changed its mind
so far we haven't heard from the German
government how they're reacting to the
announcement by Turkey today last week
Turkey has already made that
announcement that they would send or
repatriate ice militants back to the
countries but as we've heard already
from the German Foreign Minister both
last week and in our footage recently is
that of course is very difficult to
confirm the nationality of those eius
militants there's a quest if there could
be fraud involved and so Germany has not
confirmed yet if the repatriated eyes
militants that Turkey wants to send
today and during the rest of the week /
if those are indeed German national if
they are indeed sent back to Germany do
we know what will happen to them here
as if heard again of course the German
authorities would then have to prove the
authority and investigate them as
joining a terrorist organization like
the so-called Islamic state is forbidden
in Germany and of course first those
people would probably be arrested under
the suspicion and then be investigated
potentially put into a pre-trial
detention and then be put to trial now
we've seen a couple of trials like this
before in Germany only in the last year
the German authorities have been
investigating 24 suspected Isis
militants who had returned to Germany
and had been putting charges for two
both of them our political correspondent
Maximiliano Koscheck reporting for us
thank you